let's talk about the elephant in the
room Donald Trump Donald Trump I try my
best not to talk about Donald Trump
because that's exactly what he wants in
fact some estimates suggest that he got
over two billion dollars worth of free
media during the primaries which
subsequently helped his campaign get
launched into the stratosphere but it's
difficult not to talk about Donald Trump
I want to share a tweet that he sent out
yesterday essentially blaming and now
you can see it there on your screen of
course there is a large scale voter
fraud happening on and before Election
Day why do Republicans league leaders
deny what is going on so naive so this
goes into the Donald Trump narrative
I've never seen someone with so much
money so much quote-unquote success be
such a victim and cry about the
inevitable loss that he's going to
suffer so he's already baking it into
the system that the that the election is
rigged that there's going to be voter
fraud and and I think it's important to
identify what he's talking about
specifically he's not talking about
election fraud Pat he's not talking
about voter suppression because
historically Republicans have
overwhelmingly benefited from voter
suppression they are the ones doing
everything they can to make sure that
people particularly people of color
minorities are inhibited from our
stopped from voting by voter ID laws and
anything they can think of to suppress
the vote so when he says election when
he says voter fraud he's specifically
talking about this idea that people are
quote unquote voting from the grave
people died he said only on a radio
broadcaster on a television broadcast
that people who died 10 years ago are
now voting and he's trying to plant this
seed as a justification of why he's
going to lose because his internal
polling is probably telling them that
the same thing that everyone other poll
is telling him he's going to get his
butt handed to him in November and so
he's already trying to make the case
that it was rigged there's a couple of
things that happens here one this is a
dangerous game to be playing we take for
granted the
peaceful transfer of power in the United
States but the only real guarantee to a
peaceful transfer of power is the
concession speech by the person who
loses the person who loses is expected
to usher his followers his or her
followers to the broader American body
politic and say okay we lost and we're
going to support the winner without that
there really is no guarantee that
there's going to be a peaceful transfer
of power and don't Trump blaming
everyone for his condition or the fact
that he is going to lose and lose very
bigly really sets up a dangerous
precedent I don't know what do you what
do you think you look like you here
something's on your mind Pat what do you
think about that absolutely so I mean he
just has to save face because the whole
past year or two he's been playing
himself up as this big winner right uh
any concession speech is a peaceful
transition of power is one of the most
important things that we have in our
democracy you look at the two thousand
election it was very disputed al gore
ended up losing to george w bush not
because of the vote counts but just
because the supreme court handed it to
him and even after all that even though
I'll gordon accept even though he didn't
agree with the decision that the Supreme
Court made he still decided to accept it
we don't think the Trump is gonna be
doing the same thing here he's gonna go
down kicking and screaming right which
which his running mate mike pence had to
go on the sunday political shows and
essentially make the case that okay no
we will respect the winner but while
he's saying that the actual nominee
Donald Trump is suggesting that if he
loses it's only because the election is
rigged and I'm glad you brought up two
thousand i was there and i remember very
clearly we were upset and had al gore
not conceded the second time there could
have been a you know in the most extreme
case a violent revolution armed against
the institution particularly the supreme
court and so by him doing that he
guaranteed the continuation of h
peaceful transfer of power which i think
we take for granted because it does not
have to happen and Donald Trump seems to
be the very type of person the type of
person that would under
mind that peaceful transfer of power so
we want to keep our eyes on someone like
Donald Trump I think there's a lot more
going on there I think it may be some
political jujitsu he's trying to depress
the vote he's trying to even set himself
up after the fact even there's another
image I think they're from him blaming
the media um yeah media bias alert that
he tweeted out ninety-six percent of the
presidential campaign donations from
journalists have all gone to Hillary
Clinton this gives the impression that
the journalists are in the tank for
Hillary Clinton I agree to a certain
extent but these are free moral human
beings like moral agents not free moral
human beings but free moral agents they
decide who they want to give donations
to or not but I think this is all part
of a strategy trying to make sure that
he's properly set up for this media
empire that people are suggesting that
he wants to kick off after he gets his
butt kicked in November